Tamm stop it I'm unbreakable unbreakable
[Music]
patches the hyena the spider the
trustworthy the unbreakable the fact he
makes it to the end of the world never
truly Halloween is nothing short of
incredible
for we've come across countless undead
who lost their humanity in pursuit of a
purpose yet long after they're gone
patches remains any undead who makes it
to the end of the world is certainly
worthy of a second glance
for surely patches isn't as
straightforward as he seems though you'd
be forgiven for thinking otherwise
there's a fine stash of treasure right
down that hole I'll strip your corpse
clean wait now you didn't actually fall
down then everybody makes mistakes I'm
not above it all I swear we're on the
same side aren't trusty patches the one
and only patches is clearly in love with
tricking everyone for profit but for a
man who allegedly reviles the greed of
men and claims to be devoid of all
worldly wants is the profit truly what
drives him in this endless task
I think his greed is a front a facade
designed to hide his true purpose which
is to punish the greed and the want of
others every agency if tainted by the
greed of men rubbish to one such as I
devoid of all worldly wants time and
time again were lured by our greed
eventually finding a somewhat loyal
friend in patches after our punishment
is delivered but across all these worlds
there is one man that patches truly were
friends and this friendship gives us a
rare insight into what he values this
friendship is with grey rat ah I see you
angry right
the slinking round but he did me a good
turn back in LA three dungeon darris I
should do something about that little
date well maybe not well I hardly
believe he's still standing gray rat to
the thief once fancied himself a martyr
for the poor the souls version of Robin
Hood if you like it was his concern
fathers that led him to climb the Great
Wall to lothric where he freed patches
from the lothric dungeon before being
locked away in a Cell of his own
awaiting your rescue I don't want to sit
around and die and Betty Rhonda and I
consider myself your friend indebted to
you and with all those he loves dead
grep dedicates himself fully to your
cause even embarking upon suicidal
thieving runs through the most dangerous
territories it's these actions that lead
patches to his uncharacteristic concern
hey what happened to brain wrap any help
I had said what's all lately if you know
where he's carried off to be sure and
tell me now I need to stock up and if
he's gone unquote he'll have left a cold
wine but all the way to where I feel I
see it can't be much left of that frozen
spool
drag he's come off the deep a in this
time he makes an effort to hide his
affection for this man though his
actions betray that he cares for dressed
once again in the armor of the onion
night to hide his identity its patches
not secret that actually rescues gray
rat in aerosol I might have died if it
wasn't for that peculiar onion night so
of all the men to save white gray Rhett
well grey red is much like patches you
can see what they have in common they're
both petty thieves yet gray rat is one
who acts without concern for himself he
doesn't steal out of greed sir patches
respects him often lottery the cost with
no return that all thieves lost it if
you think there's a chance in there it's
quite a new to this game what's got into
you
yet patches also does outlive him the
curse of life is the curse of want after
all and if we view greed as the reason
that many Hollow and die then it makes
sense that patches is the one perfectly
suited to resist the curse by resisting
want and greed entirely if he thrives
upon punishing others for their greed so
with no want and grounded by his desire
to punish others for their wanted to
trick them and trap them patches makes
it to the end of the world but slowly
the world is ending and soon there's no
one left to lure into his traps there's
no one else to trick with their own
greed so it seems the patches to wave is
in his duty for here at World's End even
he loses himself which gives us a
glimpse of the good heart that he used
to have before the world made him what
he was I'm a hollow yes I try to play it
off but I haven't a clue about my past
who I was or what I live for
not even my own blessed name you
remember that treasure
well I fetched it for you here go ahead
it's yours maybe it'll help you with
that solemn duty of yours I'm off in
search of the purging Monument once I
find it everything will come back to me
who I was what I lived for what my name
was and what terrible grudges are held I
don't know I just have this feeling that
that's the kind of man I was the purging
monument has the power to purge the
undead curse and restore one's humanity
ironically only by displaying humanity
can it be found what did I come here in
search of Tam stop it
I'm unbreakable unbreakable ah please
someone tell me Who am I why am I here
with your help lap confined the purging
monument and surely lamp is to be
trusted
are you certain of that no sir sorry I
know you'd never lie to me thank you
thank you kindly I swear upon my birth
name that I am your friend no matter
what might come out no matter what I was
if you would do me the honor allow me to
be a true friend always at first glance
what's to come
simply seems like more of the same from
lap from patches finally you've come now
I know exactly who I was and for that
I've a little thanks to be giving go
this way and peep past the broken
staircase some awfully fine treasures
just sitting there all alone it'll
change your life
the swift kick down a hole fills you
with frustration till you realize that
is actually kicked you where you want to
go to the ledge that leads out of this
graveyard a setback that allows you to
know forward every age it seems is
tainted by the greed of men rubbish to
one such as I devoid of all worldly
wants
[Music]
[Laughter]
maybe it's just the way we are I'll
stick you in my prayers our fine Dark
Soul to you for the first time patches
helps you on your quest in a perfectly
fitting way he sets you on the path to
the Church of Fillion or where he
assists you one last time in your quest
to weaken the Lord's grip on the Ring
City he did always despise clerics
charlatans he calls them and it's
fitting beyond words that patches would
play a part in undoing the greatest lie
of all undoing the greed of the gods
that's rooted in faith in Fillion or and
in fire here you both stand at the end
of the world Undead unbroken yet we too
could not be more different patches
fought for no one but himself for no
cause other than to scoff at the greed
of men but you he seen your kind time
and time and time again and he outlived
you all those who lost everything and
grasped for the faintest glimmer of hope
kind-hearted fools doomed by the very
light that guides them he's seen men
throw away their lives for the truth for
to an undead life is meaningless patches
probably figures why seek the truth when
greater men have tried and gone mad as a
result even with the truth in tow there
is no fate for us other than the loss of
self because even if your selfless you
can't save everyone
no matter how hard you tried in the end
you couldn't save a single soul and the
more you try to help the more you fight
against evil the more you will lose
before you're doomed to lose those
closest to you
family friends some may even turn
against you for even with your boundless
compassion no one can foretell the
consequences of your good intentions all
of this it's just want and greed in some
shape or another a desire to look back
at something that made your life
worthwhile whether it's a thirst for
knowledge
a desperate faith some petty revenge
it's taken some crestfallen Men eons to
find something worth fighting for and
even then their faded to lose it all for
even the gods are in despair the Lord's
shy from their duty and the last fire is
fading but something sets you two apart
and maybe the one thing that you both
have in common is that you never looked
back
another thing I've never looked back
from is switching from Skype to discord
and you guys know that I've actually
never done a sponsorship on this channel
but this is the exception because I've
never been approached by a company that
I believed in until now discord is free
there's no ads and it's your best option
for chatting with your mates creating
your own server and even for getting in
touch with me because we now finally
have our own public community server so
click the link below and you can join us
over where you can talk Souls law and
video on a platform that's really just
designed for us and if you're a part of
this server in a few weeks then I want
to do an event where I give you guys the
chance to invade me in Dark Souls 3 and
if you bait me you get the chance to win
some high-quality Dark Souls much so
stay tuned for that thank you for
watching this video as always and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
[Music]